[Musique]
deux cent mille 44 merci aux 200
millions 44 qui sont arrivés depuis bâle
0-0 c'est grâce à vous 15h27 vous et
comment on fait pour les familles 100 me
jean-paul vous avez une petite coupe
chez vous servez vous avoir donné une
coupe rené de champagne ce que vous
voulez mais on est tous foule
allez on s'est un peu fait le champagne
[Musique]
est ressorti à quelle heure des
médicaments moi j'aime bien voir à 200
milles j'ai pas vu maman est stérile
comme a tous envie 5h d'appels
l'objectif fin d'année c'est 300 m
j'avais 10 500 milles mais je pense que
globalement on n'arrivera pas à moins de
trous de châtrés nord et 300 me fallait
abonnez-vous 300 me fin décembre grâce à
abonnez vous grâce à vous tous à
monsieur les rares touches avec le sait
vous pour vous autrement et et
et en ville à la bonne vôtre sans fil
des années alors tenté d'allumer 11 est
hantée il est parti tout seul le
conseiller sylvain lemay
merci merci bon c'était course était bon
gars et les forces péter les deux cent
mille à des gros jitsu creux nantais de
gros merci à demain à bientôt
ciao